Again,
I'd have to say
the first thing everyone should ask
themselves is what does it mean to be
realistic and is realistic,
the same thing as resigning.
The second thing is to acknowledge that
more is possible in your life that
almost anybody ever told you,
and the third is to think about the
following thought experiment which was
brought up by content.
It's so it's.
I find it very helpful,
carved in discrete terms.
This was the 18th century.
He asks us to imagine a man who cannot
resist,
says he can't resist temptation.
Every time he walks by a certain house,
I mean it's a brothel,
but if you put a gallows in front of the
brothel and he knew that he would go to
be hung,
the minute he walked out,
he would find that he could resist
temptation very well.
Okay,
so we all agree that love of life trumps
every other physical desire that you
have.
Whether it's for sex or food or whatever
form of pleasure does it for you.
Love of life is the basis of every other
pleasure.
Then imagine the same man is asked to
sign a letter condemning an innocent
person to death and he's threatened by
an unjust tyrant with death himself,
unless he cooperates in the innocent
man's death.
And what concept is is none of us know
what we would do in that situation.
Most of us would probably be cowards,
but all of us know what we should do and
all of us therefore know that we would
be free to do the right thing and to
refuse to participate in injustice even
if it would cost our own lives.
And I think furthermore,
I think everybody can perform that
experiment.
I've tried it out on a number of people.
I think furthermore that everybody has
one hero either in real life or in
fiction,
who they would like to be in at least
one moment.
You may think you can't live up to that
person,
but you have one person who you think
would act rightly in that situation.
I think we should keep those people in
mind.
Of course,
hopefully being a good person doesn't
involve sacrificing your life and in
fact,
sometimes it's easier to be good and
rather banal and simple way is that it
is to go out in one great heroic
gesture.
So I think the last thing in being a
good person that's important to
remember,
if evil can be banal and I think it can
be goodness is also,
but now to it consistent,
ordinary,
everyday action.